[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you
20 strong chess players from nine
Federation's compete in st. Louis u.s.
chess champs calm presents the third
annual winter just classic hello and
welcome to the 2019 winter chess classic
here in st. Louis we will be your host
for this event my name is national
master Caleb Dundee and I'm joined by
the wonderful woman Grandmaster Sabina
foyer thanks for having me yeah of
course it's a pleasure to have you with
us here in the studio and of course it
is a star-studded Winter Classic this
year who are some of your favorite
players going in oh it's going to be
really tough to say someone I guess it's
such a strong field that we have a lot
of very strong American chess players
right and then a lot of you know
foreigners coming here to win the title
so I don't know I I don't the big whom
I'm going to be rooting for of course my
fiancee grandma Sarah more idea body but
for the a group I haven't made up my
mind just yet so well why don't we take
a look at who exactly is playing in the
a group with our a group field we have
the only the one and only Grandmaster
Jeffrey Zhang from the United States
with a feat a rating of 27 12 he is just
within striking distance I think of
actually passing to Cara Nakamura within
around 20 to 30 points now and he's he's
been closer yes he had some great
tournaments recently in the World Cup
knocking out some really tall players in
the world so he's definitely you know
he's been one of the top players in the
US and now he's getting so close to the
top three or right
yeah the top four now our buddy a
switching yeah you might be making us
seem so yeah it would be unheard of for
Cara Nakamura and not have of a spot on
the US Olympian team but it could happen
with Geoffrey Jon coming up and we also
have Alexis tirana from Russia the
number two seed record Oberyn also
representing the Russian
but he's living in the United States now
he's actually yeah the Missouri chess
team has recruited him in the first year
of their program
Sam studyin from the United States of
course needs no introduction one of the
brightest juniors in the u.s. behind
Geoffrey Zhang we're not Jumma buyeth
from Kazakhstan is here sethu from India
is playing Varro Cobian the st. Louis
native is of course in this event
Ivana's caboose Ian returns from Armenia
Viktor Erdos from Hungary and rounding
out the a group
Daniel na Radetzky has recently been
making some waves I think in the online
chess community yes I'm a live stream I
think he was working on his he was in
university for a long time he used to
take like one one year old I think yeah
and I'm back and I would only see him in
the US Championship a few times I got
the chance to talk to him and he's a
very smart you know young man and it's
nice to see him back in the field
yeah I don't know him personally that
well but he always struck me as a very
focused chess player you know when he
set his mind to to whatever he's working
on he he really gets it done that's he's
also an accomplished author now as well
yeah and he writes a lot for just life I
think every every shares of just Life
magazine he has an article there so yeah
definitely good to see Daniel here in
st. Louis and hopefully you can do well
this tournament we see him there over
the board hard at work which is 20
minutes on his clock well why don't we
take a look at the players in the B
group as well sounds great
we have Sergey Azeroth from Belarus the
number one seed in the beaker following
him is Sergey Aaron Burke representing
the United States
Emilio Cordova from Peru Federico Perez
poncy from Argentina el Shawn Marathi
Abadi the commentators pick for the B
group to Tigran root Union from Armenia
we have Alexi Sorkin from Russia Melek
cotton from the United States and
rounding out the B group are actually
two youngsters the number one and number
two you 14 players in the Americas
Justin Wang and Christopher you are both
in this event hoping to gain some rating
points and make a name for themselves
early on definitely and I'm sure they're
trying to get their GM norms I actually
played against Justin Bank some years
ago after I had won the US Championship
actually here in San Luis there was one
of these invitational tournament I
thought okay definitely I'm going to
beat this kid but no yeah he had a
really great positional understanding
then and I lost so it's yeah interesting
to see them playing here no it's
actually bit of a surprise for me I
think I had heard Justin winnings name a
few years ago and I saw that he was you
know a very promising player and then it
feels like I blinked and he's an
international master 2468 Ryan hit Grand
Master and that's true it seems as I've
happened right under my nose and same as
Christopher you I believe he's trying to
be one of the youngest grandmasters ink
mm-hmm not sure he's - yeah I run for
that but yeah I think under age 14 he's
still very much on the list of youngest
ever if he were to make it quite and
he's also famous for having won in world
chess composition so it's really
interesting to see some of the
youngsters being passionate about you
know playing chess getting better but
also doing other things like playing
online but composing - because I think
composing is a really beautiful I think
that's really I think he got actually
some award for for like component just a
junior composer actual I think he got
like third place in some actual
composition yeah yeah world world
composition and I think it was under 23
or 26 years old yes I think that's
amazing for his young age yeah and we
see him making his movies right there
well why don't we move along to the
tournament format see what kind of time
control these players are playing there
of course - ten player round robins
that's the a group and the behavior that
we just took a look at and the time
control for this event is the standard
one for most of these tournaments you
have 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
and then 30 minutes added on for the
remainder of the game there's of course
a 30 second increment for move one we do
have a draw rule in effect
this tournament there are no draw offers
allowed before blacks 30th move of
course the game could still be drawn by
repetition of course that's always great
because that's inspires more fighting
chess yes I'm looking forward to seeing
some decisive results here definitely
and lastly let's take a look at the
schedule for the events today of course
is Sunday November 10th kicking off
round 1 starting at 1:00 p.m. our show
of course starts at 3:30 p.m. every day
besides for the final day so these
players no rest day in this event they
will be playing one game a day all
starting at 1 p.m. until the final day
where we start a couple hours early to
make room for a playoff of course we're
happy to have you guys here joining us
online on youtube if you want to follow
along watch the games for yourself you
can do so on us chess chance comm of
course so you can chat with us here in
the YouTube chat we're taking a look at
that I see Patrick Daly is here as
always
press play digital gravity the business
Rhea Lopez and checkmate is watching so
I'm very interesting user teams there
I'm glad to have you guys here with us
you also want to get involved on Twitter
you can do so with the hashtag winter
chess classic and we will be taking a
look at some of those throughout the
show as well well it's time to jump into
it let's look at some chance to look at
some chess games around one pairings for
the a group are as follows alexei
Serrano is playing green and Juma by of
Sam 7 squares off against Mizzou
Mizzou's Grigory Oberon Havana's caboose
Ian plays Varro Cobian Daniel narrowed
its key squares off against Victor Erdos
and our key matchup of the day is
between the Group 1 top seed Jeffrey
Zhang and Sethu from India and their
game is quite interesting in fact it it
might be close to ending so what what
happened here so this is the current
position that we have right now but I
think we should go back yeah in the
opening and see how did we get into this
crazy position with the king completely
opened so ok so we had a 45 Knight of 3
we see a scotch this is very interesting
is one I think this is an opening that
is played these days a lot in top-level
you ask my students to play this as well
actually with white they're doing great
but it starts four nights sometimes I
tell them play nice III first develop
your lines and then do well a big reason
for it is is there's all these annoying
lines against the Royal apes' now that
black is just proving the quality it
seems like a lot of the time yeah so
white players seem to be branching out a
little bit more trying things like the
Scotch trying other things to get a game
yeah I think it's great and it's nice to
sometimes see some of these players
start with u44 there's a lot of opening
knowledge that they have and I always
think it's not easy for other players to
understand how come they can do all that
maybe we can ask some of our guests if
they will come interviewed by by us to
see how do they make the decisions maybe
we can try to peek into some of the
grandmasters minds and yeah don't know
but we would love to get Geoffrey in for
an interview I think if he manages to
win this game
especially we'll pick his brain about
his thoughts on this tournament his
opening perhaps see what he has in store
for us let's do that but meanwhile let's
see so negative six is one the main
lines here in this position for black if
you are a beginner probably you are
considering to trade the night in
default but that's not really such a
great idea because you're helping oops
you're helping white get the Queen out
in the game and actually afterwards you
don't have a new night with which you're
going to chase it away so you should not
do that try to look for a moves like
Knight f6 or maybe Bishop c5 yeah
there's some conflicting rules there
right you know we tell beginners not to
develop the Queen in the opening yeah
but at the same time if the Queen's on a
solid square where it can't be chased
around then it's just an active piece
that's true so you have to ensure
sometimes you're learning some things
and then you have to learn to to bend
the rules a little bit and and try to to
improve your knowledge anyways so let's
see how the game wins so I think so far
is pretty
pretty normal what do you think to my
knowledge if I'm no Scotch theoretician
but one takes d5 C takes d5 and this is
kind of you know now black is could say
that they're happy because they got rid
of their double pawns here and they have
a pond in the center but not to worry
because white is going to finish their
development really fast and that's
exactly what Jeffrey did by castling now
we start having ideas to take advantage
of the King in the centres of course
black has to rush they should be seven
and now see four I really like this this
this idea yeah White has this advantage
in development so he does something
immediately right he doesn't kind of
just sit on it and let black finish
development he strikes in the center yes
and it's always important when your
opponent has a pawn in the center you
shouldn't let them just have a pawn in
the center you should try to find a way
to get rid of that pawn because you know
you try to have your own space so that's
what Jeffrey is doing with c4 and we see
castle
C takes D 5 and now cetera man went for
Bishop d7 he's not rushing to take the
pawn back because he wants to make sure
he doesn't stay behind in development
Knight c3 Knight takes d5 thinks so far
still seems pretty normal for black I'm
not actually super familiar with this
opening this position looks new to me
but that's that's not to say it's it's
not still a theoretical position but
it's my eyes it just looks pretty
comfortable for white yeah just a c7
pawn which looks a little bit testy and
these bishops looking at the ships the
c7 isolated pawn and yeah I mean if you
get the chance to trade one of the
bishops like it actually happen in the
game you might be okay but you have to
be careful afterwards because if you end
up trading one of the bishops then you
have to see how you're going to place
your pawns in front of the king and if
you will go for g6 after trading the
dark square bishop then it might be a
problem because well we'll see the game
for those who haven't watched yet let's
let's let them a little bit in suspense
say if I got positions like this I I
would start playing the Scotch every
game that's true actually is very
comfortable very pleasant I think it
something went wrong for setting here in
the opening yeah we'll have to check
this after after today's yeah so what
what happened next Bishop f6 and he took
Queen takes f6 this is still pretty
normal but now crazy too looking at
these two pawns and the bishop on b7 is
also loose yes I wonder like where
exactly was the the mistake and maybe
this is still theory although I feel
like maybe uh I I don't want to jump
around too much if we go back right
after c4 castle and I thought that
struck me is a little bit odd
maybe deforms c4 looks like the most
natural move to me it is kind of
overextending a little bit perhaps and
this was Geoffrey's idea but I feel like
you need to keep this Center pawn this
is your compensation for the leading
development yes something like this
maybe like try to keep protected
postponed over there but still going to
be so easy because what's the funny
ideas here what if white plays b4 in
this position all right
that's showing crazy like this maybe of
course if you take before there that we
may for check you have to be careful and
so about those white is playing very
very immediately with Bishop b2 and
perhaps this is what drove Sethi away
from from playing like this but maybe
just a difficult position for for black
already well maybe maybe black can try
to castle in this position and then do
you want to play Bishop b2 is my idea
immediately you know you don't have that
check anymore
so we have you take before I'll take d4
true true so we could get into such a
position yeah maybe the thymus is a
better idea
there's also maybe just just a three
yeah my idea was something with c5 and
even if you know I won't be able to
create to maintain a protected postpone
at least try to have you know create a
weakness for you as well like over here
you know this spawning c4 would both
have postponed but maybe weakness as
well yeah I think we're in agreement
that castles mind adjust spent a little
bit maybe this was the move yeah but
okay what has happened in the game let's
go back to submissive f6 so Seth is
trying to trade the dark square bishop
thinking okay White has some active
pieces let's try to get rid of them and
that makes sense
Bishop takes f6 he takes but not crazy -
so we've seen it so far and of course
here you have to try to make up your
mind which of these two pawns are going
to give up so I think it makes sense to
give up this and the game has actually
been completed I believe Sethi who has
resigned this game against Jeffrey Zhang
so why don't we quickly run through and
yeah maybe we can ask Jeffrey's opinion
exactly what how much Theory did he have
how much preparation he go ahead so g6
was played in the game
Queen 67 and I was saying that I think
it's good to give up that point compared
to them okay and so there's this idea
where both bishops are a little bit
loose that is true but Oh Queen to d4
and now look after do you want and
really like this one I think this is a
really good move you really do not want
to trade those fish shops um so yeah we
will finish taking a look at this game
first I believe four varnas caboose ian
has actually also won his game and how
great is gonna happen for an interview
in just a second so maybe you can run
through the rest of this game very
quickly
well I swap out here and we go sounds
good alright let's do that alright so in
this position
Seth played Bishop d5 trying to escape
with the bishop from the attack but this
does not seem to be a very Oh tough I
wonder if there was any other move the
black with a plate here it's not so easy
to to find an escape for for black in
this position so Bishop d5 and now I
have this beautiful discovery that
probably Seth has seen has calculated a
little bit but the their black scheme
here is not very safe after Bishop takes
h7 you know you do have the extra piece
but you are
not going to survive very much with that
king in h7 and we have seen the result
actually was changed to the result was
in Geoffrey's favor so for sure it was
very unpleasant definitely will will
have Geoffrey coming soon but right now
I think we're getting ready for okay all
right
Quincey - look II one King g6 and now h3
hmm very interesting move I like this
age three and for some reason I'm not
getting the entire game until the end
I'm not sure if this was the end or I'm
having some internet issues but yeah a
very beautiful game and I believe maybe
look at your age for could have been the
last mole of the game and there's no way
to stop the maids
or all right okay how Hanukkah boozing
thank you so much for joining us today
you had that beautiful game
unfortunately we haven't had the time to
look at it just yet
would you like to thanks for being here
and would you like to take us through
the game organizers for such a great
event I always enjoy to play in st.
Louis yeah so it's it to the game sorry
alright so you played against one of our
San Luis favorites our locals far are
you guys friends to play against your
friends don't matter
okay so did your preparation go as play
well more or less okay I was prepared to
then we'll some word I guess I could
have click with the forest Kimura was
the same but here I'm giving my opponent
an opportunity after Ricky want to play
with the five so you family 45 isn't so
good it's a lie query will know theory
yes Ricky what's a five and now it
switched to King's Indian switch colors
I wasn't sure about tempos because my
opponent is spending K 65 and he's
playing boy so it looks like I have my
work when you want which isn't great
thinking suppose you want to play for
sure and it may work on that one for a
force something like that so it this
person should be around eco I thought I
have a little bit initiative I was
trying to attack you see five pound so
yeah but before and I see the first kind
of standard because it's not so easy for
ya otherwise it may work only one would
be great so differs were logical move
holding the position here I was
expecting to see Queen c7 d7 and maybe
you'd play for yeah I was going to play
for and worried like typical position
for King's Indian I don't know custom
ideas for maybe yeah and then you go
back to have fun and maybe recap one
immediately or maybe a little bit later
but when the very poorly played 97 a
and again I don't have time for a finite
because there isn't I don't have an i -
4 square so here is simply differently I
played with a more normal to subdue
Fayette castle stopping before and here
I played Bishop a story which isn't
really happening in King's Indian
because wait what's Bishop usually being
Quneitra so in a positive colors
position here this movies attacking pawn
on e5 at the same time after some
Knights move Knight f6 or war where it
is in the future I'm gonna change this
picture which isn't the good one for me
so yeah I was kind of happy with this
exchange of course what's finishing is
fine but then you way it's a game so we
are trying to play your favorite
positions of course yeah this is this
seems to be like really really good for
you are still playable I mean we are
playing Cindy and you have less space
and you need to exchange some pieces to
have better and of course this is your
bed Bishop always yeah of course
exchanging my word Bishop on see it for
example only six is gonna be great so
exchanging this Bishop for me I felt
this is a great deal yeah okay so he
went crazy seven and then a fire
fighters I'm not sure about that first
but what I was trying to do to stop this
be 6a 6b five but playing gate 5 I
initially I missed a good chance by
black so a 3/5 Berg beat was a very good
move now b5 is coming and they can stop
it cuz be five ticks ticks so I was
gonna prepare against these p5 somehow
maybe c3 so I wasn't sure what I'm gonna
do but word bait was a very good move
that's my opening play tonight f6 I
didn't like it because it gave me a good
chance to attract some weaknesses yeah
of course g6 because if I didn't move
for example any like we should be 1795
is hanging because nine text text and we
should be 4:23
so he can't wait and after playing G
sixth right where I use this g6 move
later yeah of course it's a big weakness
yeah we can't wear by the way so take
Citrix yeah now I need my queendom
betray so I'm gonna still stop b5 after
it before how it happened in the game
day 5 and that of course you have to
take takes on a 8 my general idea is to
have my queen I'm [ __ ] we're attacking
PC
aiming for f7 in some positions and of
course yeah an f7 f7r suddenly is is
weak for black yeah well I I feel like
some potential like at some point if I
manage to play Knight g5 it may be too
hard for blacks to defend all the
weakness it's 97 here is the only move I
guess because it stops Bishop and I
defer but Bishop f6 I was happy about
this move
I'd really like Bishop h6 I think you
are you're just bringing your final
piece closer to you I'm closing for
example if I play some kind of like
Bishop d2 my opponent will be able to
play King g7 h6 that consolidate blacks
Kings position and it's gonna be not so
simple for me but after Bishop h6 I get
many attacking ideas just only because
this Bishop was there may be some h4 h5
at some point yeah even though what I
was gonna do here I was happened in the
game for example after Cooney 7 I was
going to activate my robe so he takes d4
it looks a little bit strange because
I'm giving my opponents e5 square but
it's where I can create because if black
plays he takes before in the previous
position I was gonna click five and six
is a step above so for example Queen a4
even changing the Queen's which is but
you also have something like 96 maybe
not yeah I mean the other Queen a for it
takes takes c6 it should be winning that
I don't know I didn't say any defense
for black so just crushing cold inside
and all your pawns although they might
seem weak sometimes you can't really get
that yeah so position is just great
Blake poem the King points out they're
gonna be hanging so yeah if I know there
is I I feel this position is lost for
Blake I didn't say I guess nice e5
doesn't doesn't require those be sick so
I think between b6 and I don't have an
intermediate loss no nothing cuz I can
take coin c6 and c1 is probably take
here first and no 95 is an ID yeah well
I was thinking yeah but there's this
beautiful idea let's just see sure maybe
this and then if I take in d3 just
probably take it okay so Bishop c5 and
now I'd be six at play and I'm the
texture we sure about this move because
in a couple of moves i blundered my
piece oh I was super surprised because
I've heard to be a witch
we move by the way I was thinking what
night a five-night here instead of for
eBay so night a five
I was gonna play Queen d5 and Bishop d6
is the only move could Knight b6 isn't
possible and this it's a good player
just before there is an ID fighter is 95
but I said before winning back the piece
and of course I'm gonna crush because
and with all the polls King gets under
where strong attack so just before his
winning and yeah repeat probably was the
only move and here I played 95 I was
worth it because I said I'm waiting can
I did did you miss me I was completely
surprised so looks the end 98 is the
worst form of protecting f7 well taking
this night away from this Steve file so
I'm just clearly losing a piece and I
found I guess only the idea in the
position is very beautiful 25 I'm sure
yeah Bishop v6 and Queen d6 other link
we see Queenie 7 is coming and yeah
background yes so in the game I think
here is only move for black is Bishop a5
so be Queen e7 Bishop before Queen e8 we
should be fate mm-hmm because in declare
it happened in the game
and there is no difference so either I'm
meeting from EA tour f8
yeah so any move I just point we have
people as well yeah this was very good
this one I saw but I blunder 98 so well
it's good that you had something yes
they did really blunder it just means no
way you have some nice pieces the
attacking like you should have something
yeah oh well beautiful game I I really
appreciate you coming down here and
walking us through the game we hope to
see you again in the future and we wish
you good luck for the rigors of the
tournament thank you
all right thank you again for this
beautiful game and commentary we're
going to have I'm told Jeffrey Zhang
coming into the studio very soon - what
custard that beautiful game that we
looked at a little bit earlier I'm
really looking forward to see what he
thinks
well to hear his thoughts and also if
you guys have questions for Jeffery make
sure you send them into the chat
I believe caleb is going to help me
maybe address some of them or we will
try to address any of your questions
and yeah it's so exciting to to have
Jeffery here in the second I'm going to
pull up his game and hi Jeffrey thank
you so much for joining us today first
of all I want to say congratulations for
your recent results I've been following
with a lot of interest your progress and
tell us a little bit about today's game
oh how do you know about the game or how
much preparation did you have for this
game so yeah I tried this kind of
fashionable idea in the Scotch to play
after Knight f6 takes on c6 takes Bishop
d3 the main move is of course II five
and it's more ya sharp but this one has
been tried recently
so after d5 takes takes this is all the
most normal so this castle here the best
move for black we were not sure we're
discussing it a little bit yeah d4 is
another main move this is the one Giri
played what I've been to no they I mean
they plays Bishop g5 92
this kind of position where I have a
blockade he has the past pawn but it's
kind of double-edged but castle I think
is more solid takes Bishop d7 93-95
Bishop d2 but here I think he made a
mistake by taking on c3 we weren't sure
if it was here a little bit earlier so
this is probably already giving you
someone I think so the bishops being
very strong yeah he has to keep the
tension somehow with another movie a for
example but after 93 bishops III the
promised queen d5 of Queen G for
attacking and defending mm-hmm so he
tried Bishop f6 and then f6 is not the
possibility cuz we should see for ya
all right so Bishop f6 but it seems like
here it just might goes your way after
Bishop f6 yes surprisingly this double
attack it's not easy to deal with
do you think maybe blacks should try to
give up the C pawn I'm in started to
give up the H pawn instead of the C pawn
yeah that's trying to do it but for
example let's say you try rook FDA
taking shape
the key idea for me I think is to play
Bishop f5 because a Bishop d3 d4 my you
know I was thinking maybe e4 but that
was new for me I guess maybe they could
train and then be doing so but Bishop f5
I think is is good because if he tries
worth before for example route d1 hey
I'm a senior Hey yeah rook F for I like
this idea with Bishop age 32
on g2 and also cover see it for example
mm-hmm and I used to have pressure there
yeah it should be just a queen yes sorry
so a g6 and then when takes t7 maybe he
shouldn't go for me - yeah he probably
has to try Bishop g5 but it's also not
much compensation I go b3 and yes he me
he can try rook FCA okay today we're
gonna see Quinn 85 is strong here hit
the bishop if Queen g5 this should be
for is important very annoying yeah and
what do you think it's not easy for him
to generate any play on yeah I mean it
seems like they should be able to
somehow bring a rope to a rook lift but
there's I don't I don't see any way with
it at least if you had the b-pawn he
could try somebody six but yeah that
phone is canceled I was thinking he's
not really gay maybe a five instead of
work I've see it here a five try some a4
maybe don't try to undermine your
protection of this chain of ponds and
just but no I think Queen c5 is good
maybe once again look yeah and now we're
a for Bishop g6 I think okay yeah and
you're not you're never scared right
that these positions you might not be
able to win rate you're really
comfortable like saying you would get I
don't know Queen these bishops will be
traded and you stay with the b-pawn and
you have the Queen's in
I think the bishop in game it's always
very smooth but in broken game it's
always tricky
yeah but the Queen's probably should be
helpful for you right - keeping we
should be he can trade for instance
Queen c6 but as I said with bishop still
on the board yeah just support it is
yeah alright so queen's eggs b2 and then
yeah the thing he missed from afar was
after Queen d4 okay do you want a
negative yeah he wanted a bishop e4 and
at first it looks fine for black but I
have this ship c2 and unfortunately he
can't move the Queen and protect the
bishop yeah
there's no place for it okay so that's
those is he probably has thought about
this a little bit long time before this
but I'm saying okay yeah and also
unfortunate for him is in the game the
sacrifice just works out perfectly
Bishop d5
yeah Bishop takes yeah I mean the his
scheme was so so weak I I was sure
you're going to be able to to have a
mate here because just your looks can
come so easily and then rookie one of
course right and then h3 I like this one
yeah I I also like but I realize after
that rook afford much is just finishing
Foster the key is after Bishop at five
he has to stop the queen of six I go
rook f3 yes what I missed was I thought
he goes rook a hey hey hey
yes and I couldn't see the force mate
but I realized it's just rookie three
teenage driver h3 King g6 Queen g3 and
then beautiful but h3 seems like a
really nice probably bacteria no but it
turned out that he goes rookie and here
I realize it's not completely trivial I
didn't actually get the refresh didn't
even refreshed immediately I thought the
game was actually over here but uh I
guess there are a few more moves
yeah root page for was strong because
at first it didn't come to me that
easily I wanted to try something like
Queen j-3 check earlier image yeah but
these ideas don't need to make mistakes
in Queen h4 or he's going to escape that
way if you don't check him right yeah
you cannot bring your rope as a bishop
right and then if you do something like
this changes g6 six or seven probably
Jesus g7 said the Queen goes to do six
yeah and you cannot just take any six
because it's not going to help they are
actually helping him bring any of these
yeah so Brooke h4 was important so I
kind of box his King a little bit so
King is nowhere to go
it looks like he's kind of in looks gone
here yeah he and you have ideas like
this right coming up yes okay there are
two important lines I guess if f6 I have
Queen h5 and rookie six
so that rookie states with g4 and yeah
Quinn right yeah he can give some check
on Zachary but you can also play g3 or
something yeah so the other one is what
he played Bishop of five Quincy six and
now you're bringing a final person to
again very it seemed like such a
straightforward game that to me it
wasn't so obvious where black really
made a mistake but not that we went
through the game with you a little bit
it kind of makes a lot of sense that
should have tried a little bit earlier
to keep some tensions and not not be
greedy
I guess we're taking the bishop what
what have you done recently how how come
you've you've started improving so much
would you mind sharing some secrets with
with the audience yeah honestly I'm not
sure kind of around summer time I found
some kind of breakthrough I didn't feel
like I did something special or
something but sometimes it happens like
all of a sudden you just pulled together
a string of results and everything's
going well so yeah hopefully I can just
keep playing well and keep rising yeah
we we're certainly looking up to see all
your success we thank you for coming to
join us we hope you will come again in
the future
rounds and good luck in this tournament
hopefully you're going to great thanks
so alright thanks Jeffrey for joining us
we are going to be looking a little bit
at some footage from the tournament hall
as you can see everyone is really
focused we are going to get Caleb back
in to join me to do some more
commentaries we probably start looking a
little bit at the big group it's really
exciting chess happening absolutely and
what a wonderful interview will
interviews from govision as well as
Jeffrey Zhang the two co-leaders now in
the egg group both winning their first
round without too much difficulty very
clean games although I guess and Ivana
this case it got a little bit scary when
he dropped that that piece off but
rushing activity yeah and he said it was
just like for a moment you know it
happened to me often times that I
thought oh how is it possible I thought
I was waiting and then suddenly where
did this move come from always these
moments of panic yeah but but he
certainly didn't really like it wasn't a
real blunder so right so yeah why don't
we take a look finally at what's going
on in the B group with our B group
pairings of course so much action in the
a group we can't forget that there are
actually two round robins going on so in
the B room we have Malik Pocheon playing
against Sergei Ehrenburg Emilio Cordova
singing against Alexi Sorkin and al-sham
neurotic Marathi Abadi has actually
already drawn his game against Frederico
Perez honza Sergei as a rough squares
off against route Union and in our key
matchup of the day we decided to go with
Justin Wang against Christopher you of
course the two youngsters of the
tournament number one and number two you
14 players in the Americas we see them
there squaring off the the youngest the
smallest players in the tournament but
certainly players to look out for these
these kids are always getting better at
crazy paces
any turning that feels like could be the
breakout one where they really take down
a lot of strong players that's true
themselves I think none of these young
players should ever be underestimated I
mean you never know how much time they
spend working on chess and as an adult
you have to do a lot of other things
no while they have visited it yeah it's
just just and what a crazy position we
have on the board why don't we pull it
up guys let's put it up whoa a lot of
things have changed since we have lost
well we have seen this actually before
going live in the show yet so it looks
very nasty pressure along the G file for
white but the bishop for the night and
then the 2h funds for black this is not
something I'm familiar with yeah
actually I would take white here I think
white is better in this position I would
say what is better than what it doesn't
seem so easy like of course the G black
of course is gonna contest the G file a
little bit probably Ritchie eight seems
like the only move to me yeah but then
there's the C and D pawn for white and
its counterparts in the black side are
the h4 and h6 bonds which don't seem to
be going anywhere very quickly that's
the problem yeah they're double pawns
and with the King being in front of my
nod black might not have such a easy way
to to improve the position like you know
if we would stain an endgame
where white first stage with a knight
and black with a bishop well depends if
that Bishop gets to enter such a tactic
I suppose but if it doesn't like if it
would be just white to move this would
be a weakness I think black should be
able to maybe get to protect that pawn
if everything gets to be trading in G
the king would come to a7 and then see
the good news for black is that this
tonight is actually a little bit stuck
on this B 5 squared yeah imagine it
jumps into c7 but then where does it go
from c7 yeah you would have to start
pushing the pawns like c4 c4 d5 this is
kind of what you would want to do but
you have to be very careful because as
you start pushing this chain of pawns
you start giving black the option to
activate their bishop and start
attacking your politics I'll be very
careful and while it's tough to bring
the King in because this bishop is
holding on to this h4 pawn and if the
chemistry is too far that phone might
start to push down the board but
actually when we take a look at what
might happen so let's say rook g8 I
think that's the
those two that so I can force this
endgame by trading off the rooks trying
to think I mean I don't see I think why
should trade I mean I was just trying to
double check is you oftentimes you're
thinking okay there's a tension what
should I do
you should always make sure that you are
trading because it's good for you not
because I think I might see close to a
winning idea actually
okay let's take stakes 97 I wanted to
play f4 here and this kind of cements my
weakness on e5 and I don't think this f4
upon is really going to be an attack of
a weakness in fact I might even put my
kinguin f3 where it stops the H pawn and
also defends my f1 I agree with that
idea the only problem would be if
somehow black would actually start
pushing this H pawn you would go take it
and then try to get there Bishop active
we have to keep that under consideration
right when you put a poem like this
definitely I mean I think it makes great
sense to stop it yeah so I guess maybe
King f cking f7 seems reasonable and I
didn't I don't know if I should waste
time playing King g2 and King f3 or if I
should just go as c4 immediately but I
think King g2 is the solid meant to
start with what's mortars about to see
force maybe this Bishop could just jump
yeah and then I could play King g2 here
or kimchi to first but yeah but how
exactly do you want to yeah it is kind
of difficult right
I think you have to comfort this is not
that simple of an egg endgame I mean I
would take white here but as soon as you
jump to d2 there's 96 ideas to look out
for see if I could perhaps even if I
care about this phone or not maybe I
don't care about that fun well it's the
B ponent and then also the ape on it
yeah for this is a lot of patents on the
cogniser yeah it should be three so I
guess I have to make one more one more
move before i activate my bishop we can
also start with Kim G - - kind of
wave is suspicion but I wind up now that
you said that maybe white actually can't
play but do you think 96 directly
actually or maybe oh yeah that like the
king component game actually looks maybe
even here I wonder maybe after f4 the
thing important game should be waiting
for white considering that you just
start grabbing all of these funds yeah I
think this this looks very promising for
Justin Mike and he would fall out to an
early lead over his youthful competitor
that's true I mean who what the game do
you want to show we go from the
beginning to see what yes absolutely
kind of opening did we deal with oh wow
okay Alec kind defense it's been a while
since I've seen this not the most
popular the most popular no because
you're developing a night early on you
don't take it by the center but of
course there are ways to control attack
the century eventually so much super
familiar with this opening but I think
Knight f3 is the main stuff white is
doing these days the the modern yeah
yeah
older longer time ago I think c4 was was
a move the white was considering it to
try to get even more space but then it's
like the four pawns yeah maybe it's a
bit too weakening yeah because you don't
really get the chance to develop all of
your pieces so alright so oh okay
so 95 he six Queen f3 okay I'm learning
I'm learning a new opening I'm not only
four player or other kind player myself
so we're in the same boat it's nice to
see new new thing so you never know when
you might be able to use it so this is
kind of a little bit like a Pyrrhic now
or modern defense right yeah just that
the knight kind of went all the way to
b6 this seems like a very principled way
to play for it for just in my opinion
where you just develop the pieces and
you make some annoying threats before
black it's because black is wasting some
time that's true and plus the knight is
certainly on the other side of the board
so that's not going to be and it looks
like we have another result
I didn't quite catch who that was I
think it was Alex SR okay so Alexi
Saranda has drawn a renown zoom abaya
that is not that was finished in a group
that's a Backson all right this game how
does he Queeny seven all right h6 okay
so he finally decided okay there's too
much pressure on day five fun we need to
make a decision right I have to take in
these six phone takes and now he's
finishing development I like it so far
he's not rushing with the castle because
maybe he can keep some options open and
it's always nice when you have the
ability to develop some pieces with
temple yeah you should do that as often
as you can
so d5 and ideally why it's gonna take so
now no more Castle for black bear okay
in these positions I it doesn't matter
that much I believe because black has
this kind of nice idea that they can
bring the King to h7 and the king will
be pretty safe by around these pawns
cash flowing by hand yeah and now Knight
takes eh no I'm not sure if that I would
have done that have taken the bishop but
okay Knight takes eh c3 okay so so far
we're seeing developer okay even better
than than my idea Bishop is f6 and and
King g7 although this this Square might
remain weak at some point
yeah the rook seems a little tied down
at the moment for the moment yet
especially because we have this kind of
ideas with Queen h3 and then Justin goes
for jockey one nice more threatening
moves ya know just as we've seen with
tempo and it's I don't know it just
seems difficult for black honestly yeah
I thought I thought he was more more of
a positional player but I think he likes
dynamics for sure h3 93 okay so this is
a nice idea now you're not so sure where
you want to place this night right so
oftentimes you would go 90 to bring it
to f3 maybe go towards e5 it's kind of
funny think 93 might actually be
for the g4 square which is kind of silly
to say but you can imagine it it looks
like a fire so if black plays a six
maybe stopping night b5 now all of a
sudden the night comes to see - exactly
I'm c2 it comes to e3 and from e3 it
gets to this G square so 93 an attacking
move on the kingside that's true that's
that's very well said yeah I've seen
this happening sometimes and it's
functionary sorry you know cuz you think
just often times of natural moves then I
always like to see some creative players
coming for something okay so now
obviously there's a little thread so he
went for a for Bishop g5 we do not trade
Josefa shops that Bishop very nice for
white of course during this week dark
squares for black 94 Queen e2 alright so
now he didn't want to bring his night to
e3 just yet because we don't want to
allow the bishop to capture maybe well
there's a 92 thread as well directly out
this direction but even later I mean
yeah after okay six he didn't play so I
think that was the reason right well
yeah I think actually white might not be
unhappy with the trade of the bishop for
the night
but black is kind of making threats in
every turn right like rook b6 might be a
problem now yeah I mean definitely this
Knight needs to be more moved so I found
this interesting to go back and now
you're going for b5 because now this is
an outpost it's like is committed to a5
weakening the B 5 squared and plus we
have ideas with a 19 b5 and the bishop
in h2 which we often can forget about
he's coming back into play Bishop fh4
Rock f1 okay no weaknesses for white
we're not going to try any kinds of g3
that would make no sense I just want to
make sure everything stays protected
ninety-five I do animation we actually
do have another result in Griffey Amelia
Cordova has drawn his game against
Alexis Oregon and that results in the
second draw of the day for the beaker
great not many decisive results that
alright alright baby
Bishop Bishop c2 night of 623 hmm
I'm looking at some sacrifices I think
Justin is as well yeah okay good bud
so how does black defense night they
said a very interesting lateral defense
hmm but what about in this position so
in this position Justin played Bishop e5
I'm thinking in 97 maybe no no no I
would not trade that night no thanks c7
when I think about this one Caleb this
one looks very interesting I wanted to
do the the brute force approach right
take on a seven and then I take on take
it easy but I don't think there's
amazing you know I mean we were joking
about it but it there's no there's no
mate I mean we can put it for the for
the audience just yes but well I think
your idea is kind of similar where maybe
Knight takes c6 would be possible would
be but I think it even here it isn't
enough even just giving up the night
rather than the rook looks like Rick c6
except on the board and then what can be
done for whites
I was actually thinking you know some
sacrifices but I guess maybe they don't
really work as as well as I anticipated
it somehow black has put all of his
pieces on the dark squares and he seems
to control them just well enough to
prevent these sacrificial ideas what
about something like this would it be
too much Queen g3 Vince don't really
have something very serious yet special
takes you six and then take I want too
much sacrifices yeah
I guess I saw those two great games and
you're feeling like now okay there
should be some sacrifice but it's tough
to play like Jeffrey's young though yeah
of course he seems to have a way with it
what it would actually happen in the
game on here yeah let's see if it should
be five maybe ninety seven is not not
that great it just feels like you want
to play the move because you don't want
to trade them right but okay so knight
c6 Bishop f4 g5 okay so he attracted
some weaknesses in a way so now he's
going back to h2 this might remind us a
little bit of the gap Uzi on this game
actually where he played Bishop FBI for
tracting g6
and now we see kind of a similar this
this youngsters they learn fast
yeah there's Thursday's process right
where when you're getting attacked the
the best rule of thumb is to not touch
any of your pawns in front of your King
the farther up the board your pawns move
actually the more weaknesses are created
we see here at g5 actually the light
squares have been even further weakens
now White has access to this h7 square H
5 and F 5 squares also becoming a little
bit more Ricans and sometimes they do
it's also acts kind of as a hook right
certainly yes g5 pawn in someone's yeah
and open up a file that would be great
to the F file to be open and then get to
the team that didn't really happen in
the game considering that we know the
final position the position that we
looked at earlier so f4 okay I like this
idea he does try to use this Jeep on to
hook
yeah and now we have okay so now we have
capturing e5 and that's why the pawn
structure has changed a little bit F
pawn to kini v and I like this idea I
mean of course you want to open up the F
file for white right
but now you blocked your efile so 94
okay so now you want this pawn so how
did feels like white just controlled too
many squares there there's just no way
no good home for this this knight on f6
if it retreated back maybe to d7 instead
of coming up to e4 I think maybe the
pressure on the King would just be be
far too great I think so I'm flavouring
f1 Rick takes f7 is coming in and then
there are typical mates Queen g6 another
low coming to f1 maybe of course never
gonna Jade pinned down to controlling
age 7 now that was g5 week for sure
yes has been pushed so he's he thought
oh we actually seem to have the results
of the game looking at the board it's
looks like White has more nights yeah
and we do see the King's placed on the
light squares signifying that Justin has
defeated his opponent here so what do we
kind of quickly run through and yeah
yeah let's see what what happened
exactly and then maybe we can have
Justin yes that'd be a great that would
be possible we'll give them some time to
get down here though h7 okay so this is
my position all right so did they do
what weeks but oh yeah yet the rooks
were traded oh wait wait wait wait that
was our another is maybe we can refresh
nice refresh it a double click I think
is I did there you go alright so let's
go back yeah let's make sure that we are
looking at the right position so what
did we have we have something we had
something news right g1 uh-oh Bishop g5
so he did not trade the roaster right so
this is this is I guess the the only
other way for black to try yeah it's
right to pressure
maybe keep the fish up you know out that
was kind of but but the problem is you
leave the Cystic square and we have seen
previously that that's going to be very
annoying a lot of these ponds are going
to fall the h3 is a very nice to move
from white preventing any bishop before
with the tempo and now this bishop will
never really have time scape because
probably if you make some random move
okay I don't want to make 96 because
that would be a tactic just just let's
just imagine something like this this is
something that black would consider
doing you know like putting a baby three
rook c7 here and then she's six that's
what I was trying to kind of show that I
just want to show this rook 6 736 Ricky
7 and then Bishop g3 I think it's coming
no but I think I can take your pawn
right maybe take here first if you do
that ah yeah no it's problematic yeah
but yeah of course Bishop e3 yeah that's
that's something very typical of course
here the look is hanging so
unfortunately with black you don't
really have the opportunity but I guess
Christopher was trying to get something
like this you know and then you get
blocked and you know even if you know
you get to take the exchange it will be
a little bit hard no too hard here
because you do have the ability to open
files yes
but oftentimes people think okay I have
an exchange app I'm going to win the
game but it's not always really like
that if you don't have files to actually
get your looks active an exchange
doesn't always yea help you win the game
so alright so he played 96 definitely
stolen his night there was a great idea
f4 beautiful ok so he made that
sacrifice now trading the rooks Knight
takes b7 and here these pawns are not
going to do much and I guess Bishop c1
is not taking sufficient pawns that a
pawn probably is going to improve the
986 perfectly controls all the dark
squares and I think actually we have
Justin Wang ready to come in for an
interview so once again I will be
stepping out
and Justin come in talk a little bit
about this game sounds great meanwhile
maybe we can look at these other results
yes yes maybe you can pull some results
from the a group hopefully No all right
let's drop between al-sham you're out of
your body in the middle so let's see so
okay so this was well this was a pretty
closed game we definitely have to look
at that a little bit that's and then the
draw between ocean and the response of
Frederico all right another draw here
for us and we have just in here with us
today thanks for joining us Justin how
are how are you feeling after your win
congratulation for first of all you
don't think your play was good on this
blunder okay so let's let's look at your
game okay so what did you expect the
defense no so but you had some
preparation look like right I didn't
have any I didn't look at anything you
didn't look at anything you just tried
to play some remember if I'm not a fine
line okay yeah so okay if it's easier
for you yeah [ __ ] you Bishop c4 96 we
really like this Knight g5 idea that you
played because I just remembered
something like photo from the aberration
like I didn't okay so maybe longer time
ago or something it seems really nice I
really like the fact that you know
you're you're coming you made a lot of
most attempt for you
had looked like you had a lot of
dynamics going on in the game just going
for I think this was all the variants
okay
so either killer but not in they were
computer okay still theory no think so
okay so this is and then 98 98 and then
see three of them basically that's how
much you know yeah basically and then I
said yeah yeah I liked we liked our
position of each FF snake you know I did
you think of something else for black
babies black had something the dogs like
had g5 age for something so what did you
plan against g5 what to do Kenny 500
Bishop III and then h5 you say well some
kind of plan like that maybe didn't know
no you always think it's like this H do
you just okay just let him play and then
we can his position work it's party to
more aggressive here's me turn up some
trouble with his King though right yeah
so I I don't know what the plan for
package what about if he's trying some
maybe minority attack over on this side
of the board like if I maybe yeah cuz he
play Bishop so now you played you do
really like him but maybe in this
position like it's down 96 93 maybe
instead of 96 maybe maybe can try a 6
and try to be 5 something like that d6
noisy too
b5 and then they put it in place for
about by 93 here I are coming really
fast would you fall right yeah
it's my whole player with my TV yeah
yeah we we thought about that and then
next I played a voice so if I pledge
five is going to be really weakening my
position but that's your can you
sacrifice your thinking rather your
piece 1930 fighters wings that takes d5
just wins Bishop Bishop takes right yeah
then you just loosen me okay
or just a seasick yeah that's yeah it
seems really weak wait for a black eye
at first when you took the the bishop in
c8 I didn't think that was so good
because the bishop doesn't do anything
but it seems like without the bishop
black's pawn structure even if it's a
change it's really it's it's really kind
of like you're just annoying flame like
really highs here you can just play
without Bishop here mm-hmm okay so let's
go back to to the normal - to your game
so you had some you got into a position
like this right yeah I don't know what
you're doing when did you think you were
winning I don't know I think I was
winning like I don't know like working
is but like if I got to be five square
basically I always think I'm sorry plus
the time as well so especially okay how
how do you force yourself to play so
fast how come give some other youngsters
some tips how you play so fast like I
think he just placed him moving and
after in other who he'd just spend
another 10 minutes like I just take 20
seconds like he spent 10 minutes not one
move I gonna take 20 seconds they spend
10 minutes on another movement I see so
but like how do you do it dude I don't
know I definitely I just plain natural
movement acquainted and so you heard
this is the tip we have to play natural
moves and alright well I just don't know
how you do a trick nice
it seemed to us that you've got a really
really great position this is the plan
is really good right and did you ever
think that you you were able to actually
sacrificing in e6 and try to mate
calculate but only with nine rc7 maybe
and that's why I placed bishop on their
floor because I can take on 86 this was
the moment that I was thinking or maybe
after we played this Bishop before I
really like this attracts another
weakness and then after negative seven
this was a moment that I thought you
could maybe or or even a move before but
this is a 36 yeah I didn't see a follow
up here I don't think he can sacrifice
our dinner or maybe I have some kind of
like longer term but it's not like I'm
like I mean like so it's better to keep
pieces on the board and only sacrificing
yeah so I just make you a g5 and that
kinda sounds good alright well any any
other thoughts about the trailer main
ceiling
I just completely miss a 500 like 95 ft
5 94 and and queen of three uh-huh here
take take rook f8 okay we're coming H
ones in our far ways oh you miss miss
but it seems like you still have a
pretty yeah I'm ready to and then I was
kind of worried about Queen C for you I
cannot find any move
ah ha because it's not going to be easy
for you to actually get to the king can
you prepare me five like maybe no what
about this one I see do you need to play
it ok 1 maybe it's not I see hey rook I
want some tea for hmm that does seem a
little bit annoying no no those are
winning ok well that remains to be seen
to analyze later I guess but this is
certainly an interesting piece winning
yeah yeah well thanks for joining us
today
what are your thoughts for the
tournament for like coming in here
you're one of the lowest rated but
certainly you're not one of the players
that everyone can say you know you're
it's going to be easy so you are going
to put some great spice I'm sure what
what are your thoughts coming into the
tournament well I just cooked like not
to have some like I just don't want to
keep losing the game so as long as I
don't lose any lose any game it's it's
good so sounds great like I don't I
don't want to have some disaster 2008
was like just keep playing like today
you know natural moves and hopefully it
will work out in your favor
yeah ok thank you so much for joining us
and hope to see you again here in the
studio good luck in the next round all
right very interesting game and of
course you know hard fought by the two
youngsters I'm going to be joined back
by Caleb in a second alright we have one
more result it looks like a douche
Daniel narrow disc it drew against air -
Victor wow we have a lot of draws we
have had a lot of draws in the a group
and looks like we only have one game
left I believe between Samuel 7
and Gregory of Baron yeah an interesting
name from just wing it's interesting did
you say that he didn't think he played
very well yeah that's what his bad games
look like then I know I'm scared to see
his good games yeah he was saying he
didn't know the opening but then it
seemed like he knew all the way till
like after Knight takes the edge which
at first it seems like not the right
idea but he knew that that was great and
yeah well there is kind of the
difference I think between you know
memorizing the lines and then really
feeling like you you understand though I
think maybe that's more along the lines
of what he meant yeah he knew what to
play but he wasn't totally comfortable
with the position possibly but he knew
that he is much better so definitely
that was confidence and he's playing
very fast there's something to know a
lot of the time to see some of the kids
spending a lot of time not being
confident seems very confidently his
play he plays very fast so he definitely
will have a lot of interesting games I
think for us to see it I mean definitely
it will have to be on the lookout as
right now I think in the B group he is
the only player to score a full points
Wow he might be an early leader in this
trade yeah I guess that's going to be a
very interesting it's a very tough
tournament so I'm sure we will see draws
at some point but it means well as you
said there's just one game remaining in
the a group and that is the game between
Sam 7 and Grigory Oprah which we had we
haven't actually gotten a chance to look
at it so that is true but I pulled it up
from the screen so we can see the video
as well he seems uh deep in thoughts
Grigory with the classic chess player
take of twirling the palm know that
secrets can be very disturbing when
you're playing against it yeah I noticed
when I was a kid I used to do it and
then I stopped because I've stalled okay
that you have to be mindful but
thankfully his opponent is not there
right now probably some it is moving
around my feeling on the etiquette at
the board is always when it's your turn
you can kind of do whatever you want you
can twirl your pawn you can lean over
the board but on your opponent's turn
that's that's when you really need
you know ya there step away or at least
be very respectful and let them use
their time maybe yeah I have a little
bit of a different thought because it
depends for example if your time trouble
and on your time you're going to move
the board or you're going to you know
make some of this noise you can just to
concentrate your opponent's or I mean
you have to try to be mindful of your
opponent if something bothers them but
anyways I don't believe that that's an
issue at this point so we have this
interesting endgame what do you think
about this one well I like to say I'm
not a mathematician but I can't count
the number of pawns and black has more
of them you can hold on to d2 and then
he will be a pawn to the good
in the meantime blacks King and whites
King both very center center centralized
rather this be pawn for white seems to
be where the counter play is coming from
yeah there's the furthest away pospone
it's always good to have a poem like
that I guess it's a question of if black
can kind of hold everything together and
then find some way to eventually push
forward making some progress I feel like
this game will end in a drug leave there
was a move made we every see Sam writing
tonight see three check ok so we're
going to the D pawn is being traded for
the people and the more puns that come
off the board of course the closer to a
draw you get that's true but I see them
there they're going to play this a long
time probably yes of course if anybody
has chances it will be Gregorio brain
with the black pieces in fact blacks
King may be slightly closer to the Kings
side than whites but same is very
quickly yeah I mean I think he can
probably just bring his king right now
and just right can you - King III maybe
although usually don't want to keep your
pieces in the same color as your Bishop
but I think this this should be fine and
tried to get the King in front of the
pawn the bishop kind of restricts the
night for the moment although of course
opponent can bring his Knight
we also have 93 check train to push the
King back and this this should be is our
I I have a feeling it'll end in a draw
it looks like white has has more than
enough time to get back to the Kings
side and then the one extra pawn
probably isn't going to be enough yeah
so with that in mind we're expecting two
leaders in a group after the round one
action and that would be Geoffrey Zhang
and Havana's caboose Ian both on one
point out of one but we can jump back
over to the B group I guess there's
there's two games I believe right so we
have this game between McCutcheon and
Sergei Ehrenberg mm-hmm we have more end
games for fun this is great I mean this
one is a bit better than the last one we
took a look at that is true so this
position black to move here of course
black has the option to go in for a King
and pawn endgame but that King opponent
game simply looks hopeless mm-hmm of
course the pawns while they're equal the
two pawns on the Kings side for white
the F pawn in the H pawn are preventing
blacks extra pawn from being of any use
and why it will simply make a past C
pawn and then use that to distract the
King while the White King can come in
and take off all of blacks King site
pawns yes so we'll have if these go away
and the King is far away and you can you
can do d5 right like this and then try
to get the King you know get that pawn
and everything and the problem is that
black cannot push the Jeep on they have
a majority but it's located and g6 is
not going to help because why don't have
a postponed but if this the King side
pawns were a little bit further up the
board for black then maybe there's ideas
of sacrifice marzipan but with the white
pawn so close to promoting that's how it
looks like I won't make it if we had a
few moves so surrogate is not moved he's
his bishop from there I think he is
going to keep it on that diagonal the
King needs to stay let's see if White
has
hmm doesn't want to have any chances now
after d5 no I don't think baby so this
is the car position now this is the
current position so and g5 just looks
the problem in this position is that the
bishop wants to go to f8 right yeah so
you have to keep the King there to stop
it and now we have this breakthrough and
trying to create this passed pawn so d5
King D seven looks forest and it's just
going to to clean up and I believe I've
received word caching is actually doing
a Russian commentary for us in the super
bat grand chest or tournament so he
definitely had a long day today so very
impressive if he manages to actually win
this game after getting up quite quite
early in the morning today I think he
probably had to wake up at 5 a.m.
Central Time or something like that and
he finished commentary maybe about 12
and then maybe had an hour mate or
another and then he had to just start
the game I mean it seems uh who seems
pretty tough herb life to defend this
position I think played probably should
mention that the clock situation
Sergei Arenberg in his final seconds
whereas catching with a lot of time so
prominent was trying to save time
considering that he worked so much he
was trying to save time - well not not
to have to play this long so and so the
game progressed exactly as we thought
yes I think it no Bechet before safe to
call this one pretty it pretty much
stuff I was a you so I believe so yeah
right now maybe we should just play a
couple more moves so Bishop before I'm
expecting Bishop g7 and then he actually
played a key to d4 even simply just
defending the pole yeah you don't want
to give contra place in these kinds of
positions and now those two points will
be traded you know the line I was
looking
is once we take off this H pun it's
simply unstoppable yeah h sx h 7h j
coming down the board so that leaves one
final game going on and is the game
between Azeroth and tear on her route
Union which resulting the beginning
might be our game of the day but yes
Sergei of course is actually the top
seed in the event if he manages to win
here today he will move into joint first
with Justin Wang and we expect Kashia to
to win that game mom dad sir it looks
like he is a pawn to the good right now
and more pawns to follow and a safer
King and more active pieces I like
White's chances I agree yeah white
certainly has a much better position and
there can you seems to be pretty safe
the last you might invade on the first
drink if we're not careful that was not
intentional
the queen is controlling c1 for the
moment yes that we're safe there but
that also means that the Queen cannot
get activated
you know capturing an a7 and getting on
seventh ranked so might not be so easy
but let's see how can we improve the
position a little bit for white in order
to be able to get the Queen active first
peaceful for sure was definitely
something yes and good that white III
defending the first rank cutting off
Bishop a little bit yeah this is the one
night the fun you know no that's
yourself be pinned it is blacks turn so
he does get a chance to try and kind of
make the white pieces a little bit less
coordinated here but I'm not sure how
exactly he achieves that this Bishop is
kind of needed for defense of the King
and it'll be tough to make any
meaningful threats which is the rook and
the Queen mmm-maybe
age five it's five sticks out
I'm just thinking about some ideas you
know h5 maybe g4 trying to open up the
position the other side trying something
you you need you cannot stay passive in
my opinion this position black or might
also be an idea for black as well as for
H 5 H 4 H 5 H 4 with the idea of being
that if the King ever
there are perpetual ideas with maybe a
queen check on c1 in the future and then
the Queen can head back to f4 and this H
pawn does prevent this move g2 g3 just
giving us some more pressure around the
wake that is Troy yeah so if at some
point you get that King to go to h2 then
you will have a check in a for maybe in
g3 or not be possible so h1 actually was
just played I think yeah okay so hey I
still have some good ideas shall we do
like show no could the Sten leaks a
little bit umm yeah so what happened so
far in the B group is Al Shawn Murad II
Abadi drew his game against Frederico
Perez poncy and Emilio Cordova drew his
game against Alexi Sorkin and then the
only decisive game in the B group so far
is Justin weighing against Christopher
you so Justin off to the early lead
we are expecting him to be joined at
least by caution and possibly by Sergei
azeroth and both were very favorable
positions with the white pieces that is
true we can yeah I believe that game was
the only one that we not the only one
but the game between corto Cordova and
Soraka was a game that we had not looked
at would you like to we can take it try
to take a look as I really I was looking
at the final position and I thought it
was so interesting to the way the pawns
are blocked yes
so maybe we can just see what kind of
opening would lead to such position oh
okay I would not expect an English all
right let's see interesting Queen c2
mm-hmm okay so night 63 okay so now we
see the how the pawn structure turned
out to be that way okay
I don't think Knight X III is a typical
a typical move our playing disposition
he probably was black well I want to
keep the tension it makes some sense to
me so why does just committed to b3
right so why does saying I want to play
Bishop b2 and develop on this diagonal
and when I take c3 you're just making it
slightly awkward for white to achieve
that you know either as to put his queen
and in front of the bishop on the
diagonal and Bishop f6 becomes an idea
or he has to take back with the pond
closing the diagonal momentarily
I agree but c4 is definitely something
that white can play you know later it's
not something that he cannot play and
we've seen the final position actually
it was played white does have to spend
the extra tempo that is true yeah so we
know where you are delaying them a
little bit but also our trading I like
that 19 d5 a little bit more I would
keep it but of course there are also
some ideas sometimes for wide to play
some 94 maybe you first have to play a
tree or something
anyways that was just there was just the
thought so
okay so Emilio Cordova just finished his
development he's not in a rush to push
before because of course you do not want
to let black to play 94 especially
because now you have your Queen and
Bishop you don't want to to give up the
great Bishop definitely age six a three
okay that's nice a very natural more
stopping that before and then you know
okay okay so we have some very
principled chess in this tournament so
far I think with some blunders at some
point by some some of the players which
is only natural at some point to happen
okay so of course why does not want to
give the pair of bishops so he retreated
Bishop e2 f4 if you see by the way any
more changes if the games please yeah I
think cotton is actually on the verge of
winning this game
he has just played a very funny move
which is Bishop FA check let's run back
to that games is its current yeah and I
believe we actually see some score
sheets thing signed
I think Cotchin has officially won this
game moving into joint first with Justin
Wang in the B group so we can pull it
may be the final positions here alright
so he took in in g7 and now he comes to
C pawn c6
no there's what the bishop has to decide
between stopping the C pawn or defending
the H bond the bishop doesn't problem
defends the H con and then we see the
very funny move from white bishop f8
yeah that's pruners and then Bishop d6
and now the King has a clear path been
through d5 and the e6 and there's simply
nothing to be done before laughing
definitely fortress so interesting very
very you know long game and tough game
and he pulled it through even if he's
been working early in the game so yes is
definitely a long day for tachi if
anything he'll be a little bit more well
rested for the rest of this tournament
possibly you never know this is Sam o on
no sleep maybe you know running on
coffee and Finance will power alone and
would be excited to see his chest in the
rest of the tournament that's true yeah
I know he's dedicated to be a chess
coach so it's nice to see him Beca into
into the game and playing some
tournament himself and yes show show
some good yourselves well there are just
two games remaining in round one of the
winter chess classic and that is this
game you see on the left and that is
between of course Azeroth and Hooton
Union and the game you see on the right
in the a group is between Sam Sabean and
Gregorio proned both games still going
on Craig Ori trying to prove something
with this extra pawn but it will be
quite difficult and Sergei still quite
early on in this game
maneuvering around trying to prove
something against the black king yeah
still an extra pawn so he's trying to
take advantage of that you you cannot
give up when you have an extra pawn you
need to make sure you find some way to
at least push to try to get some chances
well we are nearing the end of our show
I think five o'clock is rapidly
approaching so if you guys do want to
follow these games for yourself for
yourselves see them through to their
conclusion you can do so on us chess
champs comm see the games live see the
engine analysis as well it's all up to
you
but why don't we take a look at our
final standings in the a group if we
have that results in the a group we have
Alexi Serena drawing his game against
Renata Juma buyeth Sam Savion still
trying to hold on against Grigory open
we're expecting him to be able to do so
Havana's kuboos ian is one of your Co
leaders taking down his countryman Varro
Cobian Daniel no jetski drew his game
with Viktor Erdos and Jeffrey Zhang was
a very convincing game against
definitely missing open the Kings side
using his active pieces delivering a
nasty attack so we have two leaders in
this a group possibly three in a moment
just the two and why don't we take a
look at what happened in the B group as
well
a melech option of course is just won
his game against Sergei Ehrenburg Emilio
Cordova drew against Alexis Sorokin
Alshon Murad II Abadi
drew against Frederico Perez Kwanza
Sergei Azeroth still trying to win
against tier on route Union and Justin
weighing defeating Christopher you and
those two youngsters definitely gonna
have to keep an eye on them for sure I'm
looking already for for all of this this
game 70 there's a lot to learn for both
of us and yes hopefully everyone has
enjoyed our commentary well of course we
will be here for the entirety of this
tournament nine rounds so get used to
seeing us we'll be here for it for all
of it I think you will get to see the
wonderful Ben Simon for a couple days
substituting in for me
but in addition to that we have a lot of
upcoming events to look out for
of course the toxa still India a grand
chester event is coming up directly
after this tournament ends that will be
rapid blitz and following that one not
too far away are the grand chest tour
finals definitely going to want to tune
into those as I'm gonna see which of
these top players can get it done there
well any final thoughts on the rounds
today which players impress you the most
I really well I like the two wins by
Jeffrey Zhang and Oceania yeah those
those just were very impressive and and
in the big group of course Malik's win I
guess our game Aaron Berger was
certainly something impressive right
and even Justin's game is just his game
as well and he was so creative and so
fast
yeah I'm very excited to be here I'm
thankful to be here actually yeah and
we're glad to have you here in the
studio I'm looking forward to more
commentaries with you in the next couple
of days and hopefully everyone will tune
in at 1:00 p.m. yes so one piano is the
start of the round we'll be starting at
3:30 tomorrow please be sure to come
back and join us for that with that
being said thank you all very much for
joining us and we will see you next time
for more live coverage of the winter
chess classic
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you
you
you